on va faire le point avec tamara et
jean-françois bonsoir envie2 bonsoir
c'est jean-françois vous revenez tout
juste d'ukraine bon retour alors je vais
commencer avec vous parce que vous avez
côtoyé des militaires des ukrainiens
quel est l'état d'esprit après trois
mois de guerre c'est particulier céline
parce que ça change d'abord en fonction
de là où se trouve en ukraine a
évidemment dans l'ouest du pays on
ressent moins concerné par la guerre on
est moins directement au contact avec
avec l'ennemi à part évidemment des
missiles qui tombent ici et là on a vu
par exemple des gens qui fêtait dans les
rues de vivre donc il prenait des jeunes
hommes même en âge de se battre qu'ils
prenaient une bière qui fêtait bon juste
jusqu'à la nuit disais encore exactement
donc est alors qu'ailleurs il ya des
villes fantômes comme cars qui veulent
les gens fuient ceux qui sont là
vraiment il n'ya presque pas de
restaurants ouverts c'est beaucoup plus
tendu mais je voudrais qu'il ya quand
même une confiance assez inébranlable la
part des soldats qui eux sont convaincus
qu'ils vont gagner parce qu'ils sont
convaincus que finalement ils ont raison
ils défendent leur pays et puis ils sont
aussi renforcés dans leurs convictions
parce que ils ont enregistré des
conquêtes sauter il ya évidemment kiev
qui a été qu'ils ont repoussé l'ennemi
de ce côté là c'est à kiev c'est plutôt
les russes qui sont retirés mais à
kharkiv c'est vraiment une victoire de
l'armée ukrainienne à coups d'artillerie
on a réussi à repousser les rues jusqu'à
jusqu'à la frontière avec avec la russie
et ça ça a vraiment fait monter en
flèche le moral des troupes seidler et
du côté russe qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
que la russie a quand même gagné parce
qu'elle a fait certains oui elle est pas
là où elle voulait être mais où
kilomètres carrés le oui à des gains il
ya deux villes stratégiques dont mario
paul qui est un porc et robson qui est
stratégique pour l'entrée en crimée par
voie terrestre qui sont en ce moment
occupés complètement par l'armée russe
c'est l'armée russe qui les contrôlent
ces villes-là effectuer les rites des
images qui roulent en boucle c'est ça
qui est important à la télévision russe
pour le public russe et les images des
soldes heureuse qui se promène dans ces
villes là où on est on veut instaurer le
rouble où le drapeau rouge flotte sur
les immeubles municipaux sur les écoles
où on va avoir des référendum ou
carrément pas on volt est annexée ces
territoires la sas et des victoires
symboliques pour vladimir poutine parce
que ça lui permet encore de juste
naguère auprès du peuple russe parce que
c'est évident qu'à défaut de l'avoir
emporté facilement et rapidement sa
guerre comme il l'espérait ou comme il
l'espérait s'il la remporte ça va être
sur le long terme et le très long terme
on pense souvent on va entendre souvent
comme terme une guerre d'usure qu'est ce
que ça veut dire une guerre d'usure pour
le kremlin ce contre quoi quand on
écoute la télévision russe encore où les
gens pouvaient les analystes parade sur
ses plateaux ces grands plateaux de télé
en russie aux heures de grande écoute et
continue à dire que l'ukraine ne mérite
pas d'exister que l'ukrainien ne mérite
pas d'exister en tant que langue que le
peuple ne mérite pas d'exister en tant
que peuple alors comment plus imaginer
qu'une guerre va finir sans gain
important je pense que on est en train
de préparer la population pour une
guerre d'usure est ce que ça veut dire
c'est épuisé les forces d'ukrainiens si
c'est possible puisqu'on a vu leur
ténacité éventuellement tester la
patience et la volonté des alliés de
l'ouest d'aider les grains l'ukraine à
coups de milliards donc c'est ça que
c'est vers ça qu'on se dirige en ce
moment oui et pour pour les ukrainiens
c'est une phase difficile de la guerre
un volodymyr zelensky le dis on regarde
les jours prochains ça va être difficile
les combats dans le dos de base c'est
difficile pour l'heure mais craignait
mais est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
qu'il céderait un jour ces territoires
parce que c'est ça que monsieur
kissinger dit en fait didier céline
aujourd'hui d'imaginer la demi-volée
d'immerger zielinski annoncé à la
population un accord de paix signé dans
lequel par exemple il renoncerait à la
crimée dans laquelle il renoncerait au
donbass vous savez j'ai eu un échange
avec le président macron dans lesquelles
ça a été évoqué cette question là ça le
contenu de la conversation entre deux
prises dans les craignait le président
français s'est retrouvé un peu partout
dans commenté dans la presse comme hanté
par les chroniqueurs dans lesquels
apparemment le prises dans ma cour et
demander aurait dit au président céline
ski qui se faudrait peut-être commencer
à songer à faire quelques concessions
pour permettre un divin poutine de
sauver la face
et ça une des raisons pour laquelle ça a
fuité dans la presse c'est parce que
c'est visiblement quelque chose
d'absolument inacceptable pour le
président est à l'unisson tous les
ukrainiens ont dit ah non hors des
questions bien sûr que non c'est
inacceptable et ce serait très difficile
effectivement aujourd'hui pour voler des
mérinides qui de vendre sa population
parce que on est dans une guerre de
survie une guerre existentielle et au
fur et à mesure que le coût est de plus
les lourds le coût humain le coût
économique puis ça va être difficile de
finalement de renoncer à la totalité du
territoire ukrainien et puis donc on
assiste à un moment charnière
actuellement vous l'avez dit si le
président lnd qui allie la population
attention ça va être difficile ça va
être long c'est parce que on est un
petit peu sur l'euphorie d'avoir
repoussé les russes mais là maintenant
on s'installe dans une guerre de
positions dans le domaine basse et le
oui les ukrainiens ont enregistré des
gains avec les hommes occidentale avec
et par exemple les pièces d'artillerie
donné par le canada par les états unis
avec évidemment les armes anti tanks
mais ça ça fait ça a servi dans une
première étape ça a permis de freiner
l'avancé mais après ça pour lancer une
contre offensive
c'est une autre paire de manche beaucoup
plus difficile de regagner du terrain et
beaucoup sa série de groupes courent
coûteux en vies
c'est pour ça que le président agency
demande à nouveau des armes des
livraisons d'armes et sa presse parce
que justement oui mais ils en ont besoin
le problème s'il suffit pas d'avoir des
armes il faut former les soldats pour
utiliser ces hommes là ça prend du temps
c'est le canada a formé des ukrainiens
pendant des mois et des mois ça a servi
mais après ça si on veut reformé toute
nouvelle génération de soldats à
utiliser des armes et des armes
occidentales ça sera pas du jour au
lendemain donc c'est pour ça que le
président kennedy qui dit attention on
ont signé pour longtemps ce qui se dit
sur le terrain on nous dit les gens
disent on espère avoir une victoire
avant la fin de l'année mais quel type
de victoire quel type de victoire aussi
est-ce que ça françois disent quelque
chose d'important sauver la face
permettre à poutine de sauver la face ou
posez vous la question tout qu'est ce
que ça veut dire si on lui permet de
trouver une porte de sortie honorable
dans cette bière ça veut dire qu'on
cautionne finalement tout ce qu'on lui
reproche depuis des mois les crimes de
guerre supposer qu'on est en train
d'enquêter la destruction massive vous
avez vu de quoi à l'air mario paul les
bombardements donc quel message ce
message et qu'elle précédent surtout en
créer si on lui permet de signer un
traité quelconque belle du cdd
territoire officiellement d'abord est-ce
qu'on peut faire confiance à la
signature de vladimir poutine en 2022
qu'est ce qu'elle vaut cette signature
je pense que beaucoup de gens se posent
la question après les les mensonges
qu'il a qui la perpétuent en tout cas à
maquereau à choses durant les semaines
qui ont mené à la guerre ça c'est une
chose on le laissait un excellent à cri
mais on le laissait financer une guerre
dans le donbass beaucoup se disent que
ça va pas été le cas on n'en serait pas
où est ce qu'on en ait en ukraine
aujourd'hui je pense que point de vue
voir les troupes craignant où le
président cd du territoire à ce stade ci
outre ce qu'ils aient ce qu'est ce que
la russie possédait à vendre le 24
février dont c'est inimaginable pour le
moment est difficile très difficilement
acceptable pour les ukrainiens après
tout leurs sacrifices on comprend bien
mais ça va dépend évidemment de l'aide
occidentale
totalement oui d'abord de l'aisne en
lady beaucoup en armes mais aussi de
l'aide économique parce que la russie a
été peu touché finalement par les
sanctions faudrait me le dire le rouble
a remonté touchés à hauteur de 5 à 10 %
peut-être alors que l'ukraine l'économie
de l'ukrainienne va se rétracter en six
ans 45 % exactement est possible de
faire entrer sortir les biens c'est très
très difficile avec le port d'odessa qui
est le blocus de la mer noire les buts l
ai vu céline à la frontière les que deux
camions qui qui attendent parfois une
semaine et dix heures donc ça veut dire
aussi une aide économique pour soutenir
l'économie de l'ukraine ça veut dire est
ce que l'occident va avoir la patience
et l'énergie pour pour finir continuer
d'appuyer ce conflit là confie continuer
d'appuyer l'ukraine dans ce conflit là
et continue d'appuyer à long terme il ya
toute la khl inconnue une des grandes
inconnues c'est là la santé de vladimir
poutine en parle beaucoup tous les
aspects de la vie privée de vladimir
poutine y compris sa santé c'est un
coffre fort en russie fermé à double
tour il ya énormément de rumeurs depuis
quelques semaines depuis que la guerre a
commencé sur son état de santé comme
quoi il aurait un cancer qui lit
régulièrement visité par des oncologues
on ne sait pas si c'est vrai en ayant
une vidéo de lui ce week-end avec le
cash and chrome on le voit tremblay en
fait pour garder vraiment la nuit ça se
voit pas trop mais ceci dit je pense que
toutes les spéculations autour de son
état de santé
fait que pour beaucoup il n'y a qu'une
seule façon de finir ce conflit là et
c'est la disparition de l'admirent
poutine sipa sa mort mais très
certainement le voir perdre le pouvoir
ce qui en ce moment n'est pas une option
dans la mesure où il n'est pas contesté
et de la même façon que on ne sait pas
quels sont les paramètres pour une
victoire pour vladimir poutine on peut
présumer qu'il n'a pas abandonné
son but initial et c2 d'éventuellement
occuper toute l'ukraine il est encore
très loin de ça mais ça veut pas dire
que parce qu'ils se concentrent dans
l'est aujourd'hui qu'il n'étendra pas la
guerre éventuellement comme il l'a fait
au début
marc ensemble de nick alors à suivre
merci beaucoup à vous deux c'était
vraiment très intéressant merci au
revoir